[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMANDA PALMER: I loved being
the center of attention
when I was a kid,
and I still do.
And sometimes it makes
wonderful things happen.
Like when I convinced
the neighborhood girls
to enact an a cappella
production of "Fiddler
on the Roof" on my back porch.
I played Tevya, obviously.
And sometimes it made
terrible things happen,
like when I wore a bra
to school Madonna-style
on the outside of my dress and
got sent to the principal's
office, and the principal
delivered a lecture
that I would absolutely kill
to have a recording of, just
to be able to use the line,
"You think you're so special,
Amanda.
But you're not
actually special,"
in my techno remix of
"Creep," by Radiohead.
As I moved through my life as
a street performing statue,
and later, as a
musician, I started
to understand something.
There's a difference between
wanting to be looked at
and wanting to be seen.
When you're looked at, your
eyes can stay blissfully closed.
You suck energy.
You steal the spotlight.
But when you're seen,
your eyes must be open
as you are seeing and
recognizing your witness.
You accept energy, but
you generate energy.
You create light.
One is exhibitionism.
The other is connection.
Not everybody wants
to be looked at,
but everybody wants to be seen.
Following the success of my
TED Talk, Microsoft called.
I don't know why I was
expecting a reaction, but-- just
crickets.
OK.
No, it's cool, it's
cool, it's cool.
Good.
Fine.
Microsoft called.
Oooh.
AUDIENCE: Ooooh.
AMANDA PALMER:
They were offering
to fly me to Seattle to
speak to a group of women
who worked there.
Apparently a whopping 16% of
the employees at Microsoft
were female.
I asked the speaker coordinator
what I would be speaking about.
"Whatever you want," she said.
And I started to panic.
I had no idea what
to talk about.
Crowd-sourcing?
Music?
Surely I could wax poetic for
a half an hour about something.
But these women
were actually smart,
and the Fraud Police
were paying me a call.
Fraud Police is my own
personal version of, you know,
what y'all might call
impostor syndrome.
So for two months,
I avoided coming up
with an idea worth Microsofting.
And the night before
the talk, I was
pacing frantically around Jason
Webley's Seattle houseboat,
where I was staying,
still having written
nothing, when it occurred
to me-- my mother.
She'd been retired for
a decade, but she'd
worked as a freelancer
for almost 40 years,
applying her math whiz
brain to the emerging
field of computer programming.
And growing up, I'd had no
idea of what she actually
did all day after she
threw her heels in a bag
and drove her car into
the rush hour traffic.
And whenever she started
trying to explain to me what
her job entailed, the words
blurred into a wall of noise.
I hadn't called my
mother in a while,
but now I had
something to ask her.
And I needed her.
She talked for
two hours straight
while I furiously
scribbled notes
about what it was like for
her to be one of the only
female computer programmers
at various companies
around Boston in
the '60s and '70s.
I poured myself a glass of wine.
On the other end of the
phone, on the opposite side
of the country, so did my mom.
And for the first
time, in earnest,
it was like we were
drinking together.
I listened to her stories about
the sexism and the judgment
and the weird harassment.
She told me the story about
the guy she programmed
with who got fired for looking
at too much porn on his office
computer.
"In 1970?"
"No, no, no, no, no, no, honey.
This was way later, when
we were working on Y2K.
There was internet
porn by then."
I couldn't believe
my mother had just
said the words "internet porn,"
and I asked for more stories.
"Well, you had to work
harder than the men
just to keep the job,"
she said matter-of-factly.
"And, you know, you
had to be perfect."
The way she said it hit a nerve.
"What kind of perfect?"
"Well, if a guy
messed up a project,
there was always another
job waiting for him.
But a woman, forget it.
You'd never get a job
in that town again.
And Boston was a small town.
There were only a few of us,
and the men all stuck together."
And she told me the story
of the accountant, Jerry,
who paid all the male
freelancers on time
but kept withholding
her paycheck,
claiming offhandedly that
because she "had a husband,"
she probably didn't need the
money as badly as the men did.
She asked nicely for
months, persistently,
and a check she was owed
still didn't arrive.
So one day, she called him up.
"At 6:02," she said, "when I
knew the switchboard operator
had gone home for the day and
I would get him directly."
And she said, "Hi,
Jerry, it's Kathy.
Just wondering when
we're going to be
able to process that check.
It's eight weeks late."
And when Jerry made
some grumblings
about how they would send
it out as soon as possible,
my mother said,
"What are you having
for dinner tonight, Jerry?"
I love my mom so much.
And Jerry said, "Excuse me?"
And my mother said,
"I need that money
to buy groceries
to feed my family,
and if you don't
cut my check, I'm
coming to your house
for dinner tonight.
And I don't like salmon,
and I don't like peas."
the check was on her
desk the next day.
I'd never known
any of this stuff.
But then again, I'd never asked.
And as we were wrapping up our
two-hour conversation, and well
into our second or possibly
third glasses of wine,
she said, "You know, Amanda,
one thing always bothered me.
Something you said when
you were a teenager."
Whatever this was going
to be, it was not good.
I was a terrible teenager.
An explosion of
hormones and nihilism.
"What, Mom?"
She can do this imitation
of me as a teenager that
makes me want to crawl under
a table, and she did it now.
"You said, "Mom, I'm a real
artist, and you're not.'" Oh,
god.
And then she added, more
kindly, "You know, Amanda,
you were just being
a typical teenager."
I winced, and I felt my neck
tighten and my teeth grit down
into mother
fight-or-flight mode.
And she continued, "But you
know, Amanda, you would say,
'I'm an artist.
Fuck you, Mom.
What do you know?
You're just a
computer programmer.'"
I had to admit I could totally
imagine myself saying that
as a teenager.
Maybe not the "Fuck you,
Mom" part, but still.
And then my mother
said something
that absolutely demolished
my defensiveness.
And I don't think
in all the years
I've known her,
that I've ever heard
her sound more vulnerable.
"You know, Amanda, it
always bothered me.
Because you can't see my art,
but I'm one of the best artists
I know.
And it's just that no one
can see the beautiful things
I made, because you couldn't
hang them in a gallery."
And then there was a pause,
and I took a deep breath.
"God, Mom, I'm sorry."
And she laughed, and her
voice turns cheerful again.
"Oh, don't worry, sweetie.
You were 13."
As I related this
story the next morning
to a small theater filled
with 200 women of Microsoft,
I added a confession, which
was that in all my years
of rock-and-roll, touring
around and supporting people,
and advocating for women, and
giving all these strangers
and fans permission to embrace
their inner fucking artists
and to express themselves
fully, and look
at their own work and lives
as beautiful, unique, creative
acts, I'd somehow
excluded my own mother.
And maybe, by extension, a
whole lot of other people.
And I looked out at
the women of Microsoft,
seeing present-day versions
of my 1970s programmer mom.
Maybe they all felt
thoroughly misunderstood
by their own bitchy teenage
wannabe-poet daughters.
Who knew?
So I thought about all
the things she told me
over the phone, I
said to the room.
And I thought about her work
that I couldn't possibly
comprehend, about the actual
creative work she had done.
All of that delicate,
handmade programming she
did into the dead of night,
to switch one platform
to another on some
critical company deadline.
How "outside the box"
she said that she
would think and venture to fix a
problem, and how insanely proud
she felt it worked.
And the true beauty
of those things.
And the sadness, too, because
nobody ever, you know,
clapped for her at
the end of the night.
And as I looked out
into the audience,
I saw that three or four
of the women of Microsoft
were sniffling and
dabbing their eyes.
And my own throat tightened up.
"And she couldn't hang
her work on a wall.
I can.
I do my art in public, and
people applaud all the time.
And my mom never
really got that.
And she's retired now."
After the talk, I
hugged a handful
of the women of Microsoft,
got back in my rental car,
turned the radio up to 11, and
peeled out of the office park.
Take that, Fraud Police.
[APPLAUSE]